okay so House of the Dragon episode 7 is
now out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down what happens
all the Game of Thrones Easter eggs and
how it ties in with the books this
review will contain some spoilers for
certain things to add some context but I
won't be ruining any of the major deaths
or reveals that happened down the line
now the episode itself takes place
during the red spring which was started
last week with Lena's death this
happened during the first few days of
120 AC and like our own 20s it was a
complete show shortly after this
happened Harwin ended up perishing in
the fire of harrenhal along with his
father Lionel in the book septon Eustis
actually suspected Damon of doing this
and with the murder of Lady rear Alison
might end up using him as a way to
further push that side of the family
away from the throne I'll talk about the
other events that happen in the eras we
get further into the breakdown but the
entire spring saw some major shake-ups
that will have massive ramifications for
what's to come in the future now before
we get into it I'm gonna beg you to hit
the thumbs up button and also please
click subscribe if you want your
daughters to marry my sons and we can
finally join our houses in this great
Union without the way thanks for
clicking this let's get into house of
the Dragon
[Music]
now we open the episode with Elena's
funeral and all the houses gathered
together to pay their respect hey he
shut up Dutch
that is pretty funny anyway the
sarcophagus is clearly based on the ones
that the ancient Egyptians used to bury
their pharaohs there's the seahorse
sigil that the family has on the bottom
and we can also see that there's a
strong focus on the hair around the face
like the targaryens the valerians were
known for their distinctive hairstyles
and that's why Alison became so
suspicious when raniera's kids came out
with neither the strongs in the books
were described as having brown hair and
pug noses and this is a similar sort of
thing to how Ned discovered that
cersei's kids weren't Robert baratheon's
Cersei you bloody [ __ ] you bloody
bastard
anyway every house in the Game of
Thrones World they had their own way of
doing things and just in the same way
that the targaryens cremated their dead
using dragons the valerians get a Burial
at Sea the books described how Corliss
had amassed the largest Navy in the
world and there's George RR Martin gave
the family similar deaths to what they
get at Sea during this ceremony they
took in high Valerian and also bring up
how the Waters of the Dominion of the
Merlin King this is a God In The Song of
Ice and Fire who is thought to rule over
the narrow sea valerians themselves even
claimed that they gained driftwood from
the guard after making a pact with him
he stood to God over the dead and we
watch his callus's brother Raymond
carries out the sermon Raymond of course
fought side by side with his kin in the
war of the stepstones and there's a big
scene with him and raniero later down
the line dirty Damon is now down a wife
and he starts making eyes at raniera at
the funeral before chuckling away during
the service come the end of the entry he
marries raniera after sending lane or
away and come on mate your wife's body's
not even being dumped into the sea yet
will we'll talk about how this differs
from the books later on but there were a
lot of comments on how quickly the pair
got married after losing their Partners
again this is all taking place within
the red spring and they married less
than six months after the quote-unquote
death of Elena whereas here it seems
like it's almost immediately amongst
these shots we also get Otto proudly
sporting the hand of the Kingpin once
more interestingly we can see that he
too bites his nails just like Alison she
did it due to the anxiety feeling her
witchy now likely carries two all in all
he's had this position three times now
as he also served your Harris this is
all just a power play really man it's
very much a case of Alison playing the
council with people who serve in her
best interest in order to advise the
king to do things that will benefit her
sadly Lionel was probably the best that
they'd ever be because he wasn't
self-serving and with him out of the way
the Dynamics completely changed we also
see how the greens and blacks start to
become almost like a uniform in the
century Alison and her family Don green
throughout Russian eras wear red and
black it wasn't a actually at the
wedding tournaments where the colors
started to emerge but I prefer how they
just had Alison showing up wearing it
before other characters start to use it
as a way to show Allegiance come the end
of it rainyra decides to marry Damon so
that they have a chance should things go
down as Otto said Vega is a big loss for
her side and both Eamon and Damon end up
having lots of things go down between
the dragons that used to ride together
lie together ride together bad uncles
for life now this video is sponsored by
established titles a gift that lets you
become like your favorite Lord a lady in
House of the Dragon did you know there's
a traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as a lord lady or
a lad that's why I was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land in edleston Scotland it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
with every single order they work with
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes a bit of an ego boost
on top of all this environmental stuff
because you're now a Lord leader a lady
you can officially change your name on
things like credit cards plane tickets
your dating profile whatever you want to
do as you can see here they give you an
official certificate and also details
the exact location of your unique plot
number on top of this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link below will be
placed within walking distance from my
plot depending on how many of you want
to become a lord lady a LED we can build
our unique heavy spoilerm Kingdom
together you can be like Lord Kevin
spoilers you punk I'll see you jump
establish titles have also put together
a sale where you can get an additional
10 off their massive full sale I've
linked it in the description below and
all you have to do is go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers and
enter heavy spoilers at checkout for
that additional 10 off makes for a great
last minute gift you can get yourself
involved in all the house of the drag
against drama so definitely go check it
out in the description below thanks cut
to the wake and quick correction for how
I've been pronouncing jiserus I had said
your Karis after basing it on the
audiobook I think it's more in line with
Jason so a quick correction on that now
after learning who the daddy was last
week he's having to deal with the fact
that he's lost a parent like Raynor and
Baylor but because it's a secret no one
shows him any sympathy this ends up
pushing both the brothers over the edge
later on which we'll talk about when we
get to that point go to Helena once more
playing with insects and we discover
that she's also playing with incest as
she's betrothed to her brother aegon
this is something we teased at last week
but they just out and now confirm it
here much to aegon's dismay during this
time he was doing his best homelander
impression whilst also trying to [ __ ]
every girl in King's Landing he didn't
really care about the Judy de her or the
throne and this ends up becoming a major
part of the Berks when it comes crashing
down they were married in order to keep
the blood of the Dragon pure and it
shows how fixated Alison is on this and
why she looks dad on renera because
birthing blonde head babies wasn't her
strong suit
rhaenyra tried to join their houses by
marrying off a kid to Helena last week
but Alison denied this and then quickly
married her off to her brother it also
really comes across like Helena has an
extra Dimension to her and they might
even be slowly planting the seeds that
she's an oracle or a witch huge announce
to Manuel Blackman on Twitter for
pointing out that in the last episode
she ended up saying this you will have a
dragon one day
he'll have to close an eye this is in
reference to how Eamonn will gain a
dragon and he of course loses an eye
after getting vegar she also seems to
predict the marriage of Damon and
rhaenyra with this line happens flash
weaving dragons of threat
the targaryens refer to themselves as
dragons so this may be in reference to
that well let me know below if you have
any other theories Lara stands around
just trying to get Alison's attention
and it's like when you see that weird
guy used to work without and about that
keeps trying to make eye contact reminds
me of that bit in extras when the guy in
the bar just keeps trying to grab Andy's
attention he's of course now the head of
Haron Hall and eventually he gets
pointed as the master of Whispers though
we don't get it confirmed in this
episode it is coming soon though and we
always hear this over the top by Corliss
brother will be king of course this is
basically taking a line from the buck
changing it and giving it to someone
else at one point for Sarah says one day
this will be your seat lad but this is
given to Corliss it's important to see
where his allegiances are at this point
and come the end of the episode renice
talks to him and is seeing the truth
about who his heirs really are this is
why I think she has trouble looking at
renira in the face and while she goes to
her grandchildren to comfort them whilst
pushing Jace away Eamon goes to M2 and
almost speaks up but he ends up leaving
without saying anything so at this point
that we hear the Cry of vagar and the
sun goes down they know ends up standing
in the sea crying and it very much
foreshadows the choices that he makes at
the end preferring to go to Sea rather
than being with his family though
there's a lot of drama is per usual a
man viserys is the one trying to sort
everything out I know many look at him
as being a terrible King but actually
think he was a great leader that brought
a lot of peace to the realm it was
simply those that saw the throne who
wanted to tear him down but he very much
shows that being a leader isn't all it's
cracked up to be this air is very much
followed in the footsteps of jaharis who
he viewed as bringing peace to the Seven
Kingdoms he didn't want to participate
in war and would do whatever he could to
make sure people had a good time he's
even diplomatic with Daemon and the pair
of course both lost their wives and
children during a traumatic childbirth
Damon ended up mocking bailing as the
air for a day but now the shoe is very
much on the other foot the show changed
things up a bit and in the original work
Elena did give birth to a baby but it
came out twisted and deformed she ended
up resting in bed for three days and she
got up to write Vega one last time
knowing that she would die soon she
collapsed on the tower steps and was
carried back by Damon who sat over her
with his new girl raniera viserys always
held a soft spot on his heart for his
brother because he had fond memories of
them playing together as children and
because of this he goes very easy on him
Damon also Damon yeah he drops this line
it's something you should need I need
nothing I feel this is echoing the war
on the step stones in which he preferred
to Goat alone rather than getting his
brother's help he was of course supposed
to be the heir but he was cast out and I
don't think he's ever forgiven viserys
for it as the sun goes down Alison's son
goes down to get vagar really shows the
difference between him and his older
brother who passes out on the steps and
has to be escorted off I think the thing
about Game of Thrones is that it pretty
much shows how pointless it is having
certain Bloodlines who are in charge of
everything I don't know about Georgia or
Martin's stance on the monarchy but he
seems to depict it as being something
that ultimately leads to the wrong
people being put in charge and how
stupid it is to decide leadership based
off that as we follow aemond we see how
he's a much better decision maker I
think showing aegon passed out on the
same steps that he travels down to get
his Dragon definitely seems to cement
that he had to work for his Beast
whereas aegon was handed his along with
everything else Eamonn is a badass and
watching him go to vegar is such a good
scene that night renice blames Damon for
not letting her daughter 10. but call
this is more of a level head with the
entire situation however he refuses to
see the truth about the next in line the
pride of oranice being wronged has
driven Corliss quite a lot and now he's
on a quest after the throne in order to
right the wrongs of the past renice
realizes they have lost too much in
trying to gain a legacy and she pleases
him to cast their apparent grandchildren
to the side in favor of their real ones
this will create a dark shadow over the
house but it keeps the name whereas
Rayner and Baylor will get married and
lose their surnames because of their
husband names are of course very
important in this world and we cut to
renira and Damon in sharing the
Targaryen one is cemented she's Furious
that Lena isn't keeping up appearances
and she reveals that they did try and at
least conceive a child together a lot of
people in the comments last week were
saying Leno could have at least tried to
have one to throw off suspicion but hey
sometimes it doesn't work that way
renera doesn't believe Alison had a hand
in hole instead but come the end of the
entry she does say that she's seen her
true face raniera is still blaming the
curse of Harren Hall which hilarious
prayed upon last week the curse came
into place because a lot of the owners
of the land ended up coming to Violent
ends and Superstition is used to control
the general story June discussed this R2
and how Paul was created to be the
chosen one because poor people tended to
turn to religion due to putting their
faith in things in order to get ahead
the scene is darker than the long night
the team finally kiss and get it on I
think I don't know couldn't really see
lots of focus on hands I think and
touching each other and this is mirrored
in their wedding come the end of the
episode the pair ended up having a sex
on the beach and careful mate that's the
quickest way to catch crabs
[Music]
also the over-the-shoulder shot of
raniera looking completely vacant
reminded me a lot of the one of Allison
earlier in the season I think that this
has been put in place because it's her
seeing it as a duty much like Alison did
now across the beach we cut to Eamonn
attempting to get vegar the books
describe this in more detail and they
change some things up timeline wise
giving certain elements to other
characters now this was all sparked up
with Eamon getting angry that he didn't
have a dragon his dad could see this was
all taking a toll on him and he made a
promise once they arrived at driftmark
he said that after the funeral that they
would go to Dragonstone and choose him a
hatchling or an egg instead of letting
him attempt to tame one this fueled him
on and due to it seeming like he was a
chump he decided to take matters into
his own hands this led him going after
vagar who is described as being the
largest and fiercest dragon in the realm
Vega has a rich and dense history and
she comes from Dragonstone after being
born during the century of blood this
began after the destruction of Al
valyria and it led to one of the
bloodiest times in essos Bay was
initially claimed by vicenia Targaryen
who was the wife and sister of egg on
the Conqueror she was a massive part of
aegon's conquest and helped him and his
sister sorry wives to take over six of
the Seven Kingdoms Eamonn is the latest
writer and it's a sheer bullish attitude
that helps him in the end the book
describes elderly dragons as being
something that you should be even more
cautious around but I think him being so
headstrong is what really helps them out
the series does change things up
slightly and in the source material
Geoffrey comes across him sneaking out
in the middle of the night he ended up
screaming that he had to stop but then
Eamon kicked him into a pile of dragon
droppings before taking to the skies on
Vega's back it's very much a
coming-of-age moment for him and the
show lives directly from the book with
this line
may have lost it
but I gained a dragon
it's something I've talked about in a
lot of trailer breakdown videos and
there's been lots of comments about how
gangster this line is so I'm really glad
that they included it in the show who
will get played upon later down the line
so keep that in mind as we get further
into the episodes this awakens rhaenyra
and it should be seen as her very much
waking up to a new world they've lost
the biggest dragon in the realm and she
and Damon must now marry so they can
survive what's coming a Joffrey is too
young in the show to take part in any of
the fight afterwards so it's between
Eamon and the two brothers joserus and
lucaris Rainer and Baylor are also there
and they'll they change some minor
things up overall the conclusion's still
the same Eamonn returns with a new
attitude and after he hits the twins he
gets piled on he ends up basically
saying Santa isn't real with the reveal
about Harwin to luceris and he ends up
losing an eye which is a defining moment
for the character this moment is
actually depicted in the book and though
there's very few images I felt it
necessary to show this happening because
of what it ends up leading to now from
here we jump to another major scene in
the story in which the inequality in the
family causes the houses of fracture
Alison very much wanted an eye for an
eye and she saw this not being carried
out as an injustice they've Incorporated
the Valerian dagger into this and I kind
of feel like they're almost trying to
retroactively fix the ending of Game of
Thrones every time I bring this up I
inevitably end up discussing how it was
Arya who killed an eye King rather than
Jon Snow because of this I'm going to
get into a little
so the thing that is still a way they
can incorporate this into the law and
keep the prophecy true Giorgio Arman has
been openly discussing the Jon Snow
sequel series that we'll pick up after
the events of season 8 and though Kit
Harington has said he knows nothing
about it we all know You Know Nothing
Jon Snow I can't see them doing
something that could even resurrect an
eye King as the main villain of the
spin-off series and then we could have
him end up returning from the north
sitting on the throne and then defeating
the villain and concluding the prophecy
not very Game of Thrones either give it
the Hollywood ending but you know what
it's just a theory mate just a theory so
don't lose
now in the books for Sarah's made it
illegal to question the legitimacy of
Rainier as kids they used to ride purely
from the insult by aemond as he saw how
it caused those within us in a circle to
turn against that side of the family he
didn't want this to spread to the rest
of the Kingdom but making it illegal
very much had the strides and effect in
case you don't know what that is it
became a term after Barbara Streisand
attempted to suppress photos of her
Cliffside home which was being used to
document Coastal erosion the fact she
was trying to censor it made the story
gain even more publicity and in trying
to shut things down everyone started
talking about it this was very much the
case with the kids with more and more
people learning of them potentially
being Strong's due to becoming illegal
to say that they were anyone who's
tongue
now this line is important because
there's two characters who may pop up
later on that were adamant it was true
and they ended up going to viserys to
make it clear why they were Strong's the
book says that he sat there throughout
the entire speech and listened as they
listed up all the reasons and then
ordered for their tongues to be cut out
this was something that was seemingly
changed up last episode with a scene
almost being given to Laris instead I
doubt this is gonna pop up as the moment
ended with viserys getting off the
throne but then he slipped and cut his
finger similar the ending of episode 1.
it's from that this developed into a
fever and Rainier ended up bringing her
own masters after his failed They
removed two of his fingers which we
pointed out way back in episode 3. he
ended up regaining his health but
they've reordered the timeline here to
have this open the series instead of
denying the strongs which had a knock-on
effect to him Game of Thrones Legend
states that those who aren't fit to lead
will be cursed by the throne and viserys
ignoring the truth about the kids was
what sealed its fate however in the show
it was changing the air from Damon to an
Era which could suggest that it was the
wrong decision to make so sexism I guess
either way it's now treason to declare
that the strongs aren't lenors and they
might end up reorganizing stuff in the
future to change things up Eamonn is
quickly questioned which leads him to
point the blame to aegon who has of
course been poisoned by his mother we
know
father
instead of seeing them as kids he now
sees them as Rivals because of what
Alison has done and Kristen Cole stands
there smirking away I tell you what mate
you little [ __ ] you are you're [ __ ]
dead if I catch you mate don't [ __ ]
stand there smiling mate I tell you that
one
I hate that guy now he rushes in as
Alison goes to attack and the blade
burning in front of the fire is very
symbolic Alison reveals the bitter and
jealous person she really is and she
cuts raniera's hand this later plays
into the wedding with him performing a
ritual that's similar to a blood pact
Otto goes to her and though an assault
on the princess would normally bring her
down it actually empowers her realizing
what she can get away with is very much
what Alison weaponizes in the future and
being so high up and being forgiven for
doing things like this makes Ramirez
seem weaker Elena goes to his wife and
as the saying goes the chain is only as
strong as its weakest link Lenor is
letting everyone down including not only
his wife but also his sister he ends up
leaving the realm after faking his death
which is a big change up on the books in
the series he watches Damon gives a call
enough so that the pair can run away
together but in the Box the pair fall in
spice Town Merchants reported that
they'd heard arguing and that the two
then draw their swords which resulted in
Lino's death in the book septon Eustis
said this was because Carl believed
Lenor was in love with another Knight
and this threw him into a jealous rage
theories around at the time thought that
Damon paid for him to make Elena but
there was no evidence for this in the
source material Leno was 100 killed and
his body was even brought before his
father without him being burned alive
because it happened down in spice town
there were way more witnesses than just
the boy here and thus it wasn't as easy
to fake her prize was put onto Carl's
Head And there are elements of the book
that discuss how Damon may have promised
him passage to spice town and also
Sanctuary however he apparently had him
murdered at Sea and then his body thrown
overboard which was then never recovered
much happier here and I wonder if Laino
will pop up again at some point he loses
his dreadlocks to hide his identity and
now has enough money to live freely with
his lover however he could be a wild
card but as he doesn't turn up in the
books we don't really it's impossible to
predict exactly what they're gonna do
however this does feel like a dangling
hot thread and it's going to be
interesting to see what they do with him
now at this point we could to Alison
riding across the sea and even get a
shot of her on a boat some of the ones
that we've had with viserys and rhaenyra
might be reaching here but I feel like
this symbolizes how she is the one who's
taking control the focus had certainly
been on the real Royals before this but
here appearing here now switches up this
Dynamic larus once more goes to her
offering her the opportunity to get an
eye back no Alison doesn't want this she
feels glad to have a friend in Randall
renera and Damon finally get hitched and
this Echoes egg on the Conqueror who
married his two sisters in order to
strengthen the house this Bond of Love
is shared with Lena and Carl who
actually managed to escape the Game of
Thrones their confines and the Civil War
that's forming on the horizon now as
with my thoughts on the episode I think
this was another brilliant one that
swept up in tragedy it further shows the
fall of the houses and if you know the
books and you'll know we're heading for
a big event very shortly I'll talk about
what I think will happen next in the
series but I love how this has devolved
into an almost all-out soap opera as
they fight over who will be the next in
line Billy Getty invested in the
characters and even knowing the source
material this still has me on the edge
of my seat every week I know that there
are some things in this that go against
the cannon but I'm not someone who's
completely hauled into it when it's
handled really well I think introducing
Joffrey in this with the Eamon story
would have just made too many characters
and it is smart to keep the focus on
what they did also really enjoyed how
they handled the Leno thing and after
going through The Heirs of the Dragon
section of the book every week it's nice
to get thrown a curveball once in a
while all in all great episode and I
can't believe that we're seven weeks
deep now I think the show has been so
consistent and I'm having a complete
blast with it I wanted the book spoilers
and check out now if you don't want
things ruined I'm warning you you you
don't make me cut your tongues out you
son of a [ __ ] now Ranier and Damon end
up having kids together in order to
create some true Targaryen heirs to make
things even more confusing they're
called aegon and also viserys again
which good luck trying to follow me when
I talk about that anyway I haven't seen
the promo for next week so ignore this
if it's a load of [ __ ] however if it
contains another time Jump Then I'm
guessing this will take us to 129 AC
this is the air in which viserys dies
and the dance of the Dragons finally
begins he passes away in his sleep and
his body is found by his servant who
then tells Alison and that she keeps it
a secret while she plots away with the
council earn her father scheme away and
aegon is announced as the king because
they refuse to inform an era about her
father's passing at this point in time
she's out of the kingdom and going
through childbirth the baby comes out
deformed and it apparently has a
dragon's tail it's still born and renira
blames Alison for taking its life and
also taking the throne from her in one
Fell Swoop it's a major gut punch that
causes a massive war within the kingdom
and some members of the council even get
executed for bringing up that rhaenyra
should be the queen lots to look forward
to and I hope to see you back next week
when we break it all down obviously let
me know your thoughts on the episode
comment below and yet give your
prediction to where you think the series
is gonna go we are competition right now
and giving away three copies of door 11
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe and notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on Twitter at heavyspoilers you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out our breakdown of rings of
power which will be linked on the screen
right now we go over all the ins and
outs of it talk about the big twist at
the end big Cliffhanger to definitely go
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
foreign